wirklich jüngste idee war leute heute
ganz wichtig machen nochmal eine
aufstellung mit allem was uns zur zeit
bleibt bis zum schluss dran herzlich
kommen wieder leute ich habe mir meine
kleine schwester wir sind gerade in
amsterdam hätte gerade eine spontane
idee wir mal die kamera angeschlossen
werden ist jetzt film und zwar werde ich
meiner schwester jetzt 60 minuten zeit
geben in diesen 60 minuten werde ich ihr
alles kaufen was sie an mich heran
bringen was gibt's mehr trägt und ich
würde sagen braucht noch einen stopp
ortsgemeinschaft kaymer startet in 321
ich brauche eine foundation fühlt sich
an wie fühlt sich an das jüngste
geschwister teil von drei zu sein aber
zwei brüder youtube sind und die 1
weißt du gar nicht wohl
nein das ist übrigens lara falls jemand
fragt also wenn es so weitergeht wir
nicht so viel wenn also ich meine du
kannst an sich kann das machen können
ich hätte mich beschweren also kann
jetzt schon rein weil dann nutzt du das
[Musik]
november fünf gegnern kein geld
aber wer so ein bisschen erfolg
dass wir diese andere der gastgeber aber
das war nicht ganz schlecht wie wir das
schon wieder 24
was ist das ständige bruders es gibt so
nach hinten oder so teuer wie kann
dieses kleine ding 60 euro wir sind wie
wir diese verluste macht 60 tagen über
die idee gesprochen werden ja also wir
das machen dann will ich auch nicht
teurer sei als fünf euro oder so erst
mal für 60 euro
das war so eine schlechte idee dünsten
lassen
einen schönen neuen laden losgehen was
ist das gerade banken wird das hier
einmal daten und 7
was nimmst du bei der ganzen sache darf
man auch nicht vergessen dass haben wir
einfach noch 150 euro schuldet willst du
das ja also ich war nicht so gern 15
minuten sind vorbei
60 euro in das weitermachen über 240
euro zu seinem bruder das amt wirklich
dümmste idee war leute dümmste idee aber
das gute ist ich sage mal nicht so ist
einfach nicht zur zeit einfach gehen
beziehungsweise brandy und wir sind dann
gleich wieder da und es ist die längste
weg dahin zehn minuten zehn minuten
die studienkosten leute haben einfach
navigations probleme die mädels
verbündeter und mich komplett
aufzunehmen
aber sie haben ein problem sie wollen zu
irgendwelchen leuten die mich hat ihm
gesagt haben aber wer mehr will aber
dass ihr handy später fand ich bin gucke
da es los wir haben richtige wetter
heute ist die schon weiter als könig
würde der eine ein orange oder so will
ich dir können das wäre noch drin
wir haben ja wir können sich verdienen
so wichtig macht schwimmen aber
mittlerweile weiß man finger vor die
linse haben oder riechen oder so
wirklich wie lampen hier nichts
gegenteiliges und du wirst dich du bist
youtube heute die mädels haben starbucks
erblickt für mich weil wir alle wissen
dass damals ein espresso 33 euro kostet
ein versuch undercover zu bleiben dürfe
natürlich
st
sehr gut
[Musik]
mehr
das feuer auf dem menü soll ich weißt du
wie ich das video finanzieren indem ich
einfach die 150 noch schönes
zurückverlangen
krebs ist ein geschenk der
getränkehalter wenn man nicht bezahlt
und uns eigentlich nirgendwo eingestellt
dass es mit seiner und geh einfach und
es zu nehmen was hast du gesagt ja was
machen wir heute das getränk reichen
damit die wissenschaften kümmert sich
nicht wird hängt
hier wird sich bedient gleich zwei
ketten wie teuer sind wir so kevin 16
ja diese miniserie bis die socken mit
einzel bronze sorgte größeren ich
zufrieden bist du bisher winken ja
schmeckt es doch so dass starbucks
getränk oder was schlecht
diesmal geht es in einem drogeriemarkt
noch meine aufstellung mit allem ist es
teurer
das meint 46 dabei so diensten star war
immer etwas aus der hand der handy
verboten
das war gut
das klingt doch perfekt für das video
sehen will so gut und so teuer schreibt
dass das problem wenn man das mit mädels
macht eine kosmetik der leute die sich
mittlerweile überhaupt keinen bock mehr
gerade eben einfach 54 euro durch zwei
oder drei mannschaften darauf ganz
ehrlich ich habe der frauen-oberliga dem
erzählt mache das eigentlich schon alles
auch schon dafür weiß ich uns angeguckt
hat ein auto
einfach nur noch nicht steht ist es
einfach auf dumberger gefühle während es
sinnvoll zu wählen
erster teil aber ich glaube die
günstiger würden auch nicht ganze kann
zu machen
also ich muss auch fair sein ich würde
mich seit einerseits will das gebäude
kaufen oder mieten
das ist die rede von mir egal ich habe
ja was hast du dir feines geholt wir
gucken jetzt mal hier der timer ist
dicke abgelaufen aber sebastian hat auch
ihren mann trotzdem noch bezahlt müssen
sie jetzt ein bisschen runterkommen
heute die stunde weise und dann auch nur
gleich von der kleine ausstellung was
gekauft so die müssen wir dann insofern
eine kleine ausstellung für euch habt
ihr alles fein säuberlich aufgereiht das
ist gekauft haben zuallererst waren wir
bei douglas zehnte hier 24 gekauft habe
sich auf 56 euro hier sind dadurch
richtig wurde der mann fahren dann
geht's weiter wir waren beinahe als
nächstes ist weil das schon sich doch
nur diese klar dass die knete geholt ja
klar das ist nötig war das hat mich
sieben euro kostet das wollen wir auch
bei diesem handy laden bei dem handy
laden
wer der hülle gekauft und eine folie
noch insgesamt einfach 40 euro oder auch
bezahlt oder wort starbucks waren fünf
euro bei diesem einen kosmetik klar da
habe ich auch richtig viel geblecht aber
für diese ganzen sachen ja 47 euro die
da einfach und ganz wichtig da dürfen
wir nicht vergessen weiß habe gut aber
auch noch eingekauft haben da sorgt für
die kette geholt das ganz klar mit 22
euro oder wer sie glaube ich gerade den
schaden den sie angerichtet haben
ich habe jedes mal ich habe gesagt die
künstler gehen auch wenn man sich die
augen an das sozialrecht gehabt selbst
sehr gespannt wir haben selbst ein
bisschen geschätzt was das ganze kosten
wird ich glaube auf jeden fall dass eine
ganz gute ausbeute gemacht wollte seite
werde ich leute sollte werde jetzt kommt
der gesamtpreis wir haben insgesamt
einfach 177 euro und egal leuchte last
dieses video durch die bedenken bis
verteilt dieses video mit einem cousin
drin gab es keines mit einer großeltern
diese einer müssen wir so wieder rein
und habe ich auch wieder das einen guten
tag ich wahrte seine kleine schwester
schreibens video ab jungen könnte man
kann aber nicht
und du kriegst keinen platz nach dem
video